one of the things that i think we've
done well
is is just given the people at the
company a lot of opportunity right so
you know it's not just me who started
when i was 19 and and now you know i'm
running this big company there were a
number of people who joined
who were you know people i did problem
sets with at harvard or dropped out of
stanford or you know different programs
who have grown with the company over
this long period of time and you know
one of the things that i'm the most
proud of is we have
about 12 different product groups at the
company
and
all of the people who are running them
um
with the exception of uh one uh
did not join the company running a
product group or reporting to me that's
amazing um and the one exception was
is david marcus who was the ceo of a
50 billion dollar public company so um
you know so i'm pretty happy that that
that he's on board and having him run a
product group i think is a pretty big
coup too but literally none of them
started off reporting to me um you know
they all start off in different in
different roles some were engineers some
were data analysts